why can't you just leave my daddy alone  oh cassie this must all seem like a  bunch of confusing grown-up stuff to you  huh  [Music]  your school has rules right like you  can't draw on the walls  well your daddy went to germany and drew  on the walls with captain america  and that was a violation of article 16  paragraph three of the sokovia accords  kathy let the man get by but daddy's  super sick  i'll see about that he says he doesn't  want anyone else to get sick  well i'll take my chances sweetie he  barfed  like a lot young lady i'm a federal  agent i've seen worse things than vomit  like a lot a lot yes forget it move  aside  [Music]  sir can you knock  sorry sir uh but i just got a lead  ooh i love leads  wow you're really great with kids thanks  i'm also a youth pastor  how'd you do it scott do what  the card trick seriously  did you want to grab dinner or something  i mean because i'm free  you